[Music]
girls do run the world now boston is on
course to make history today by electing
his first woman and first person of
color as mayor michelle wu is facing off
against fellow city council member
anissa sybi george both are democrats
woo who had an early lead in
pre-election polls would also be one of
the only asian american mayors in a
major u.s city assaibi george also grew
up in an immigrant family nancy chen
looks at why boston is finally ready to
embrace change at the top
the birthplace of the american
revolution has led the way with a
history of firsts but in one of the only
major u.s cities yet to elect someone
besides a white man as mayor boston
politics is now having a revolution of
its own the two of us have been on
different sides city councilors anissa
acabi george and michelle wu are facing
off in the historic race whoever wins
will not only be the first woman elected
mayor but will also be the first person
of color elected to that post did you
always want to get into politics it was
never
on any
list of imagination or possibilities at
all never who is the daughter of
taiwanese immigrants i remember growing
up and
never seeing anyone who looked like me
on tv in politics and so the thought
never crossed my mind that
one day i could be part of these
conversations isibi george relates her
parents also immigrated to the u.s her
father from tunisia i can't help but
think back to
saying to my father that i had an
interest in maybe running for office
someday and he said an arab girl with an
arab name will win nothing in this city
both assaibi george and wu say they
strive to set a new example for their
children what are the biggest issues
that boston is facing right now
it is housing affordability first and
foremost wu was the first woman of color
to serve as city council president
who had a pivotal moment in 2008
when her mother struggled with a mental
health crisis she went from being the
person who held together so much of our
family to not being able to care for
herself much less my younger sister's at
home and how did that impact
you wanting to get into politics
it was a
sense of just being
invisible when it came to the types of
help that my family needed it felt like
so many hoops to jump through i want to
be your mayor is
a former public school teacher is
focused on education and economic
recovery i think about the impact this
pandemic has had on our small businesses
i kim janey this election comes just
months after boston's acting mayor kim
janey was appointed but only temporarily
could you have even imagined this for
boston 15 years ago not even close
randarte teaches a class on female
political leadership at simmons
university why has it taken boston so
long to elect a mayor who is not a man
who is not white perceptions of voters
about how women can lead is very
important and boston does take time in
trying to make change and so while
history is about to be made both women
are focused on the future the race they
say is about more than them the first is
only relevant if there's a second third
fourth and then the door is wide open
for everyone and there's a lot more
change where this is coming from for cbs
mornings i'm nietzsche chen in boston
massachusetts
wow whatever happens in boston today
it's a new day in boston
i like what she said there the the first
only matter is if there's a second third
floor because otherwise you're the only
i like that it's a very different thing
to be yeah and that's just i be george
her father saying that a woman with that
type of man nothing and here she is
right now she said dad i think you're
wrong i love the shot in the beginning
of the two of them hugging look before a
debate very nice i know it's a mistake